the origin of the voice for k2 is a lot
of the imperial characters having mesh
accents but I did the audition initially
with a couple of other voices woman kind
like where it is speaking correctly
every word is said it is if you were
machined the captain says you are a
friend I will not kill you and luckily
have done a robot before so I had
approached it that way what would it be
like to speak robots don't breathe
that's a huge part of how we express
ourselves so I had already organized a
lot of things in my head then it's just
about the character his backstory he was
in the Empire he was a bad guy he was
reprogrammed so sort of like he had a
change of heart you know a digital
change of heart and that did affect him
I thought of him as someone who's young
because once he's taken out of the
Empire and he no longer has that
servitude he is free to be himself for
the first time I always had to wear
stilts when I was doing k2 took me a
little bit to get used to walking around
in them certain sandy beaches weren't so
great once one foot went wrong my leg
would wobble and then it just became
like I had a flat tire but I think it
got pretty good on him there were also
these robotic hands and they'd slip all
the way up to my shoulder and then they
went way past my hands and when I moved
my hands the fingers moved so I could
grab things I could pick things up I
could punch buttons and stuff it was
amazing we colored outside the lines you
know you would start out the day like
all right here's this what we're gonna
do and then everybody to start throwing
our own ideas I think I should do this
what if we do it this way where if we do
it this way it was a collaboration and
so that's how k2 came about I just work
with the other actors in the director
and made the best movie that we could
and had a blast doing it